man what's up brother it's been a while
now I miss you man what you're doing a
corporate gig
Asuna corporate gig how's that it's like
hey everybody let's get sales up Bryan
Callen done I've done I thought I
thought I thought but I blew up on
offline but first of all I take two
planes and then a car this is in Florida
oh yeah I had a panhandle
- and who cares way down go to go down -
not to the Florida though not to the big
dick of the Florida but the the handle
of it go over there to that
go ahead about an hour the sounds of
solid bamboo Florida you went to the
side piece of floor went to the side
piece of party chat ah beautiful beaches
they say some of the best beaches in the
world because they're the it's like this
myth the sand is so white yeah I don't
like that it's like only how terrific
beach hmm like a little cold yeah you
like gin there you like it called this
is this is such clear water a lot of
shark attacks and when they're always
shark attacks and start right there yeah
right there and in fact the only place
I've ever been where I go a lot of shark
to go yeah a lot of sharks out here that
bite you - I got my - everybody gotta go
south north not right here nobody in
here Ned never happened you'll see him
you know he didn't around the cab driver
meanwhile a shark expert miss little
body around here yeah Oh buddy the guy
with the apex predators migratory
pattern on his iPhone
he's got ignore it right here they don't
bother you meanwhile I'm [ __ ] order
Florida and they sitting out one of
those people till it till dusk it was
the sun's down they like to order
walking around meal and good football
I'm sorry Disneyworld good football
sharks crocks nothing else well not
about a swamps in hachi hachi hachi
there's no question hot chicks but
suntan lotion uh-huh croc uh-huh sharks
yeah and divers and dick divers dick
divers everywhere now okay and I get
there
and then I got to take a drive with a
man who is who an older man a man who
showed me a breach of them is yeah if
you've ever had a pet hamster and he
lived a 100 years old and then you
shaved him
this is what the sky looks like
literally I an old frail man and I
thought to myself this guy
I was worried because you know he's
retired and he's driving me I thought
you know he's on the road and it's kind
of a drive and I'm looking at him and
I'm just looking at him and he's gone
you know I'm trying to stay out of the
Sun and you know I'm just down here a
long time my dad moved here when I was
about nine I was like cheese yeah I'm 51
so yeah 50 were urinate you're a year
older do that son and get you it will
that bad living - that's kind of the Sun
though envision etics your hot Sun yeah
genetics - and I guess the Sun because
he had holes in the skin like you could
just see holes on your own picture here
yeah you saw I had a video that tells me
about flora Florida's Heaven's waiting
room if I guess where you go
it certainly is yeah like everyone's
like yeah this next step you're correct
I guess the step step because because I
had that human air is soft on the bones
I'm is that why all those people you
know and no taxes yeah and you don't get
as creaky though that that that soft
sticky tropical air go go light on your
bones your bones move around little
clatters on my knee
mm-hmm mm-hmm I do well there I a you
tend to be a little more flexible your
yoga stretches get a little deeper if I
hate cuz my own my skin I like a little
bit of oily skin so it always looks like
I'm sweating yeah
when we play football down like Miami
Florida State hide long hair at the time
like mean club try and growing out my
brother's side here down to here yeah
how you afford just go uh-huh
get all frizzed out yeah you get a mist
on your body get a sort of a dewy mist
on your money I'm like thinking of like
a sticky gecko like that's a big illegal
salamander yep yeah old stinky sound how
sexy Tyler Fabio salamander I understand
shitty fat so you sweat you sweat
standing still do certain time for you
Disneyworld down there I've done it hey
dude horrible too much Donna too big a
depakote center yep yep [ __ ] let's
say that's right bring the cut sir half
my god radical did how are they still
around rather be in a den how is that
still around dated [ __ ] - huh look the
moon like go look North Korea like
there's all the world stuff you know
like Kerry South Korea North Korea
Russia yeah it's all just straight up
like stereotype yep anymore because if I
get me the [ __ ] oh my god that was the
[ __ ] worse all right then just me
just do it is huge it's giant it's so
you I'm you're walking it need to
in Laos it needs a remake you need to
face list and then the water pipes down
there though good water parks yeah but
we saw watch breakout and Legionnaires
disease and weird [ __ ] sometimes yeah I
don't like I can't [ __ ] with the water
parts out there the waters lukewarm yeah
well I take hold and when it's low
pointy - require me correct when it's
lukewarm bacteria there's no truth you
pee in the pool you do pool pizza yeah
poop is I am sometimes yeah I mean let's
let it go I don't care and I feel like
when I do in the ocean whatever disease
I caught that salt gets in that in your
pipe and you're good thanks huh to be
bro sign so I feel like it cleans it out
I like my material I know my buddy rich
and he's hi giggling and we're swimming
this in Atlantic City
he he took a big old dump all right get
right in the goddamn time John luck I
gotta have known only they would have
got me out of that [ __ ] water fast was
a crocodile I don't think even that I
juggle I could have gotten out faster I
I don't care how old was you this done
oh I don't know 25 no girl men [ __ ] in
the pool or I'm sorry the my buddy did
that in the lake - at us you know I see
I draw the line there man I guess you
see what slowed up no no no no of course
you drop taking a piss I'm cool with
writing but don't [ __ ] at me [ __ ] cuz it
floats my way and I got to swim I'm
doing I'm doing the butterfly
I'm literally my mommy pulling us
pulling oh Jesus I'm running on water on
Ben we found sick man yeah and we're
gonna draw the line there Cherie how our
friends who shouldn't pulls and you know
I've had a couple I've had a couple
dolphin will have anything out no horse
she don't know because that's like going
too far right he although I will say
that there's no self-respect you know in
high so a little class in high school I
will I'm going to admit something in
high school
boarding school uh I was my friend
Sharif and his buddies were standing
Sharif was a humma I'm a germophobe
Hey Sharif that make sense
Sharif merciful Serena III was mother at
home okay Wow Jesus all right sure read
he was a bit of a germaphobe and he like
he was meet a homophone Sharif the
Muslim homophobe good buddy of mine just
super race rep they're really good
friend of my hated all non-white cities
and I just
yeah crazy really good friend of my very
close hey did not connect the room on
LinkedIn because he's a nice Estelle
Irene that's it
there's goodness matters he's a really
good guy equally respected member of
Isis he throws in gay people off
buildings other than that he's a great
guy he's new friends anyone here from
Sharif yeah man I should you like doing
the other day he's in Syria part of Isis
[ __ ] exactly
yeah he marched he marched with a
swastika um no I know but I love Sharif
Gerald's a Sharif in and he um but he
was with a couple other people and the
one thing that I bothers me is guys who
are a little bit anal and maybe keep
things to clean and neat yeah yeah and
I'll admit I did this I was senior in
high school so I was old enough to know
better and they were in the bathroom and
I walked in and I pulled out off a bunch
of like you know paper towels you put on
put on the ground wilted and truth goes
Brian what he done
Brian what are you doing what are you
doing I squatted I proved right in front
of the foot right in front of door she's
crazy I know so that they would have to
try to get around it and I enjoyed
watching like that's a bad joke well
dude you know so embarrassing I was 18
oh my god I know I'm shackled to I can
shout Sharif ass aggressively to kept no
no not that was my bathroom in in there
boarding school okay yeah no house in
this house no that's something Sasso
would do satchel just comes over shits
and go see you later
I'm like my wife and I wrote have you
touched itself it alone I have recently
is it just work too late crazy yeah but
he's in he's in Canada how about rap
pours on the Colbert show tonight really
doing on there buddy spilling his his
fire
he's great it's pure fighter he's great
about Donald Trump's son and miles of
he's a Jew now he can't stand them yeah
Jerry Lisner yeah yeah so you can't
[ __ ] stand well when Donald Trump was
going off on you know they're both sides
not all of those people less sales
that's all these I can you use have
dinner without could you say anything it
works about to Juho man and not only
that a Jared Christian was there and
also well
he was there but this is his son-in-law
you've got munchin who is his well you
have called who's his economic adviser
Kona's Jewish Munchen is his policy
advisor I think one of the positives
he's doers you could see all of and and
Kelly who's that four-star marine jet
general who is impeccable he's got
impeccable character it everybody
respects inflation he just had his he
had his arms folded he was just staring
the ground the plan the posture says a
lot to us all that the house shakes is a
lot don't please don't equate I know
they're [ __ ] heads on the let out and if
you try not to weigh down you know
people keep saying you might retire yeah
they say you can reside I told you that
before the expert who calls everything
yep yeah still sticking to it yeah well
you don't mess around it makes sense
after what I've been up to
okay ask Brennan let me ask him first of
all I'm gonna I'm gonna be honestly you
look a little tight around the body
I'm what are you up to man I'm careful
now you're gonna piss me off well but I
know something's up so be careful Matt
just careful because it's gonna make me
mad I'm already mad I don't know why I
don't be mad because you're heady I can
take all the money okay hold on I gotta
get my body I'm a pescetarian this is
new fat Oman over that's crap
I see I'm a vegetarian for three days of
the week the rest listen everybody I
don't need anything on the land right
now nothing I'm land I wish I wish I was
strong enough to give you the SmackDown
slap I want to just get on you go KKK
told ro you know straining just because
you stared at me when I said that look
says enough you don't need to I don't
need you to belittle me
it's go look does enough it's great you
exceed here's you on TV on it nope
that's tearing I guess the [ __ ] you say
lit your me what I just how long you
been in pescetarian about everybody
sorry I'm sorry for those you don't know
is somebody who eat only fish and
vegetables but no meat the only media is
fish everybody no fish no legs a pet
guitar you can a writer I'm sorry I
don't need eggs do you eat a certain
kind of fish to something that well I
don't need oily fish I eat a white fish
let's celebrate off this right now okay
Sam a lot salmon a lot of halibut made a
tilapia last night sure make these big
salads long
last you figure I don't know we'll see
man just want to mix it up you know I
got done off the road on tour ate fish
and chips every day that's kind of
pescetarian healthy but you know I just
I've been eating a lot of red meat at
home and stop let's make some grilling a
lot grill know for those you who don't
know Brennan I haven't seen sever
because you've been working like a
[ __ ] I've been working like a
mother this yeah it's tough because yeah
we don't get a chance to hang and you
know kind of be silly couple silly goose
it hurts I don't like the I don't like
it you I mean all the don't all the
influence for the corporate gig that's a
different end
yeah for the vendors Association okay
everybody here's a Haley together and my
friend Leo who are the to move on Carol
to 11 year olds in my front row home is
hard okay let me try to be metaphor that
idea yep for me it's just like grind
time right now because you get the fight
coming up and then like I'm doing you
spin up from here I go to your spin do
more stuff for them and then next week
it's off to the races yeah yeah with
Showtime all that's gonna listen to you
and break down the fight week I mean we
talked about a little bit we talked
about all sorts of [ __ ] but you know it
goes things it was great that you got
money on the fight right oh yeah yeah
I thought I had 2061 odds for Conor just
to win rounds my brother's like you're
an idiot you have fifteen to one for
Conor don't win I was like oh alright
and then I but I do have my I forget my
I don't miss cokes people jump down my
throat last time but I've three months
ago right when the fight was kind of
coming about this Vegas book you put out
odds of counting when by knockout nods
were crazy I put two grand men with our
boy Todd wow yeah so a Vegas bookie said
that there's a reactor he's put up a lot
of Atacama yeah like his yacht now
Connors all the way down to plus 400
some is the the odds were so Canelo
was a bigger underdog hopefully this is
how area but that might because the
Malignaggi cape or something oh it's
just a dissuade the public's way like
that I can see it you know and I like to
think I have something to do with them
yeah maybe your herp interpret maybe you
do I will see I'll do I take you that
picture of uh
freakin Julio Chavez senior I've never
been intimidated to go there no great
martial arts yeah even you know he
doesn't speak any English at a headset
in now I was a little bit like
iris respectively decline your argument
here
well she saw the greatest boxer in
Mexican history still Abby's right still
super beast you put on four ounce gloves
so I have to wear Boston we did this
little [ __ ] I had boxing those I'm here
at points clubs on
we're like moving around and he went to
the heavy bag started hitting it I was
like really
yeah and then he came over to me and I
was like yeah come on he went to go for
it I just single like though if you got
laughs he was great where um can I see
that is that on tape someone I don't
think so I'll see him again tonight
though you well yeah man he's great man
I'm a heel it still looks good still
looks good too legit you didn't see any
signs of any kind of again like I gotta
translate in my ear so I can't really
tell but yeah you know I don't know I
mean he's very active in his son's
corner yeah I don't know if some
slighting anymore or not I think that
last one Kenneth yeah yeah yeah so he
lives in Tijuana he got him back and
forth you Wow yeah looks like a king I
feel like I'm being excited once the
fight Scott you know over like I
appreciate all this stuff and all the
stuff I'm done once it's over so you
really focused on Stanek it's been hard
did folks out before I came out for
Anasuya come off now I'm in this yeah so
once that's done that just so I talked
like Skylar all our guys you know stay
in Tripoli I'm like I lined me up soon
and lined me up yeah I'll be on that
shows yeah because it's tough because
the other thing is that you you realize
that there's nothing there's nothing
better than they artistic sort of
endeavor of trying to get better at
something on new stuff too cuz I came
out for writing oh I do current events
on there huh so I'll pick up stuff that
I'll there's something there oh there's
something that's not like three or four
things I'm like I can do bits out of
these yeah yeah I'm excited sure that's
great I'm excited it's gonna be cool
beside the watch I've been doing nothing
but writing new stuff it's fun when
you're in that situation and it's true
like you you when you have a job when
you're working it's you're always
grateful that you're working but it
takes away from you know yeah but yeah
you know peace a pickle a that's why
some guys like oh you can only do come
and I get that but I get certain now I
get certain like like I want to have
certain perspectives if I wasn't doing
other stuff yeah I think a hundred
percent makes sense also thing I totally
disagree with feels that you can only do
stand-up I know a lot I've been in this
game a long time I know a lot of just
stand-ups and I have to say even very
good
a lot of times tend to have a very
myopic view on things and I feel like we
look like you like you but something
like you who is so good at communicating
so passionate about fighting who's now
become a voice for people to listen to
and and you know and has a unique
perspective on the game and by the way
does other things I mean you know
there's other things that you you're
capable of it's only going to inform as
you found out it's only informing your
expression you know you're starting out
of this but you've made huge gains
already and it's informing you wouldn't
you know part of the big brown breakdown
fighter and kid which creates this this
fan base allows you to go out there and
press try this stuff out so I would
totally disagree with that look at what
it's done but also the guys who say that
they're coming from TV and all this
other stuff that's right when I hear
them telling like yeah I get that but
that's right you have a TV show right
correct corrected so you shout out
computers because you should be faced
with you and I would even argue that
your lifestyle the way you work out
being a pescetarian is that all fun is
it on its inform [ __ ] I take like I'm
part of it reply back [ __ ] you I miss I
miss J I miss introducing hanging out it
was really great but it's great it's
great it's but it's it's all stuff that
you're going to find and it's going to
make its way onstage
how about the other reason again I'm
grateful for the sole reason of that
start which right now before the show
I'm waiting for my [ __ ] eyes stop
it's open at the Nitro because reminds
of Guinness I'm addicted to Guinness it
is so I wait for that nitro cold brew
and the guy comes out this lighting
grown man goes well you're really gonna
ride Ratana like this we doing this I
don't know this guy's great
I just scared I was like this do you
watch fighting he goes ass not really
went right on your head on and just
walked away I know I'm like I've seen
your back toss back man I saw its job
guy he's an [ __ ] I feel like I was
kind of funny I was heat lady saw them
just like this well somebody doesn't
watch fighting you know yeah it gets it
gets a little it's like you know just
like come on man do you have a
perspective or you just try to
you see you should hear old expert Brian
are not around but people ask me about
this is me ready
I go ahead and ask him ask me what do
you think of that the McGregor you're
talking about the greatest posture of
all the time it's going to be fun to
watch Connor miss however I will later
yeah I will say that his movements are
very very unorthodox he's got that left
hand hi Jarrett every day I feel like
Jesus Jesus cry to go look at land a
left hand I'll do one more excited for
this is how you know I'm ten percent gay
is I do custom suits made I was excited
to peacock glue but sure are there time
just [ __ ] on everyone else with their
suits well Bradley black haha boom good
dude did she do what are you a 52 or
something I don't know
you got it I mean I'm a 40 record like
dude yeah this guy's worse than all his
clients so I just guy it's off-camera in
the name with some Hollywood off less
area and he goes again didn't listen I I
don't discriminate I don't give a [ __ ]
you're gay
Jennifer I don't care I celebrate every
mom and he goes he's a little different
that's all he texting is a little
different just a heads up my different
then what's like a different I walked in
this [ __ ] makes I mean Richard
Simmons looks like the rocks he was he
was on fire almost on fire hey let's go
my godly heal me harder he got to
measure up Bourget low chalk you up a
washer here but of course you're not
going to the store just pick one off the
shelf
no you're not no you're not like I quit
that's my no no no you're not are you
and then you get Unitas let's get that
inseam I get that inseam all right we
got a certified date diamond out here we
got Jacque Cousteau take you in my own
heart like I was sweat no idea you know
the tongs you know how they're because
they see is it's booming
it's booming well don't say they seized
booming that that makes me sweat why
don't you lose some of those threads oh
yeah I had to yeah and let's go ahead
and get you out of this pan you thinking
what he said though so they take all
your measurement and try on the coats
and all that and then they have a
[ __ ] twenty books full of all these
different like
patterns all that and we're going
through them and he's like is just one
this is typically the one people pick
are you throwing a two biggest basic
what else ya like to be loud you just do
it and I keep going he does your price
spent the most time ever seen a male in
here spend on picking a suit I'm like
I'll be here all day my love do you love
it you pick you pick you down to a tee
you can pick the pattern inside button
color on the buttons what it says
something on the inside on the cloud
panicles I don't have to do that oh I
was gonna call him
boom-boom and he was what about this one
come on my man can't mix that with that
he's like you're right Jill certified
chills that's good is great really yeah
so I can't do that I loved it I can't I
mean I panic when I have to put colors
together I wish it every day if I could
blue I'll just take the blue blue and
all blue as soon as the satin whatever
you say really though and they measure
you up huh Ramez really have your slide
so if you ever want that then I don't
have to I can say hey give me this color
I come in not not giving the suits away
though right thank you away but not
crazy
not crazy yeah best to have a suit
tailored though we wanted to cheap right
it's better to have a shitty tail it
like like cheap tailored really good
tailored like a you should spend more
money on the tailor than the sue yeah if
it comes down there and you love it I
bet you like wearing that suit as much
as you like to do in color for the fight
yeah yeah I'm excited about it yeah
we'll see Tom that's exciting good I
can't wait for that what are you doing
for the fight big questions still up in
here you might be there and if you're
not I'm for sure gonna be there you are
we're at the show time and my team is
trying to figure out what exact role
I'll be working on my site right now I'm
working right we don't know if I'm the
desk I'm behind the scenes if I'm doing
around around they definitely do it out
of way I'm definitely worried you're
there yes now if when you say you're
there will you be there to see it or
will you be in a truck summer wat I'll
be in the Reno til you'll be in the
arena Kade salya
oh that is for sure yeah that's history
yeah that's incredible and then show
time I don't go ahead and face time with
it with me
just hold of Kevin yeah a stunt like
dude what are you doing like like Brian
needs a suit and I didn't get ticket I'm
just there yeah Showtime had this like
this exclusive like artist design this
poster and there's only like 100
I told Mike you have got to save me one
of those it's we dislike super arches
Floyd on one side and the Gregor and the
other like Wow please say one less Wow
because it's so historic insane do you
have anything worth of purses ah Connor
Connor his cut to view see it so I think
yes you've been around 44 million I'll
make a hundred million he's got to give
the USC 44 pretty sure he but he's
making a hundred make one hundred plot a
plot sponsorship so they say he'll
probably make around 140 mil 142 Penn on
pay-per-view numbers holy [ __ ] I'm in a
ploy to make around 160 200 they think
good hard that's [ __ ] crazy they call
it the billion the billion dollar fight
he's given generate a billion dollars
that's insane crazy right with this this
Irishman this Irishman who came in and
did everything he said he was going to
do if he [ __ ] beats for it that's a
wrongful I don't know what I'm going to
do well North ruling some nukes there's
no Wilson line or Korea and he'll beat
the [ __ ] out of Kim Jong that if he
beats Floyd it'll be it might be in many
ways will be the biggest star in the
here's what it's me I was going to say
it might be like it might be like what
he didn't UFC is this extraordinary I
think about it right I mean Josie all
done throat I mean not everybody takes
an ad lifetime is incredible Eddie
Alvarez after losing in the admin I can
beat him and they did everything he said
it's gonna do and took all comers with
such courage if he jumps into another
sport and it is another small Buffalo
being the best of all time
it's DFS as Michaels are getting I'm
getting that that tiger tooth tiger
tattoo and I'm going to start training
I'm going to move to Dublin I'm going to
clean his feet right I'm gonna be his
foot clean you will literally be the
biggest athlete of all time I think
that's it I think you could make the fat
Damon I think it was like a job you
exaggerate like god man beat familiar
the sport not even I really do I think
it's I think it's a legit statement and
I think it's also their they'll be a
magic art it's already dirty I'd like
I'm wearing a Bruce Lee on the area your
kids will be wearing a Conor McGregor's
I think so - I think select shod was
such a dick diver of Conor well what
he's done that's all I'm called it yeah
and called it every time use a hater or
your fan blade but this that's this day
and age everyone so ladies you have to
love anybody who is first of all
he's not up he's not a dick like he
knows he's a competitor and he's a
showman and he'll you know he part of
the fight for him is the psychology of
talking you out of your game and we all
love it but he's not a dick he's humble
in victory humbling because he says and
you can see it right but also the fact
that someone like this is willing to
come in and unknown I'm not here to take
part I'm here to take over do you see I
think he posted muscles on the Twitter
mentions that are the news the Ireland
soccer team was a machine yeah that yes
it had that yeah here to take part with
him yeah over yep that's why that's why
I brought it up so sick and a just you
just realized that this is a guy who is
so extraordinary in in that he said I'm
gonna do the impossible and I'm doing it
it's very inspiring basically because
you know I mean to me I'm kind of put
you I live years ago he's testing
welfare checks that's crazy - I I saw I
talked to Mack Lyon was quit I took two
Mac life guys who you know they've been
with him forever all right come on was
he really like cash cash and welfare
checks is that like an act and you've
heard people say oh I don't believe
that's not true like on ways from ya
know that yeah that's that's real man
like sure talk to anyone who grew up
with him like that but you know when we
did the podcast I tried to get out of
him what the what was the decision like
what something happened right so he's
going along he's almost going to retire
and then he obviously decided to be
great that was a decision almost right
yeah it's a very strange very futile can
do that the podcast was a while ago and
then you know it was on Fox's time so we
had what he admitted to them you want to
stay longer we're gonna back up it
becomes LA helps us we get him back on
India mazing yeah it'd be amazing yeah
get him back on because he's he's just
he is a great American to do for the
great Irish figure I'm gonna have a
get-together yes I think so
everyone critique in Philly I do it at
Frank Rose but I think he's going to be
out of town
it is gonna be yeah yeah you should
watch with Chris man it and cry together
maybe we will maybe well I just got a
text from Chris how's he doing
I think he's doing well I think he's
like I don't know it's very hard for
these guys
right what yeah it's very hard Felicia
no be right with you ranking yeah yeah I
don't know man it's a very interesting
thing
yeah Boston Tiffany I haven't talked to
him I guess he I heard him on Instagram
talking about Nanaji and how are you
talking about us I'm on a she was
furious I'm I'm you know that big soap
up and everyone's applying for attention
to the body it's amazing how much
interest fighting generates in everyone
every man I know not woman I know but
man that every man even they watch
fighting or not every man has a
primordial drive to at least talk about
it and be interesting yeah it does that
yeah it can no no not like this so guys
you don't know some guys which I
celebrate those back as why but it goes
back to like almost always who's the
toughest kid in the neighborhood right
everybody wants to know the toughest kid
in neighborhoods now everybody wants
number the toughest guy in the world is
there's always been this fascination
with fighters always especially
heavyweight fighters the fan base that
Simon ollie would generate or all those
guys especially if they had
personalities you know it's like damn I
think it worked me if I'm wrong but
heavyweights in the UFC don't they get
higher ratings typically oh yeah they do
right because people there something
about heavyweights well I mean not any
more than that not anymore
not really people do it more cuz they
know he's gonna knock sort out but even
John like you know what kind of a draw
is John and who is he's is John a gen
Jack of your water John and genatech
jaejin jack is she jumped onto your hand
came down
yeah can check she a bigger draw draw
than John D a little [ __ ] she's not even
close I don't know she's maybe a 300,000
paper you draw and then I think you know
John against DC the biggest rivalry
every ever she gets 800,000 buys so it's
not like it's modest it's not a home run
yeah Tomas it's not Tinnell little box
and it's not Floyd it's not Connor it's
not Brock Lesnar but you know that
that's where that's your biggest
starting to see what that's done sure I
want to see what kind of a triple G
generates I'd imagine big numbers
good Cannell always gets big new guys
right yeah I was that seyi's he besides
Floyd he's by far the well you know anti
Joshua grant deals on Sky Sports you
know between Cannell or Joshua there's
argument goes bigger just because it's
tough because it's it's on it's like you
didn't have to pay for it yeah
sports fills with JD I'm ill - pretty
impressive yeah when would be but - no
I'm Wembley right yeah Wembley Cannella
could do the same could he yeah I I
don't know because he did Dallas and
people like he sold out Dallas statement
holds whenever 75,000 they only were
they only did they give a cap on 50,000
it wasn't the whole arena right I don't
they're close but Josh was a heavyweight
he looks good he's you know he speaks
better in Canelo
yeah he's the killer you know he's had
bigger fights still heavyweights of the
draw so I don't know man
who's next for Joshua who does he fight
let's go retire so he's fighting this
Russian dude probably and then we'll
fight Wilder after that yeah men if I
might help
I want to see that fight Crawford fight
Saturday and let people forget about
Crawford but confer fights and then
there's a boxing's great right now man I
know the ratings just you know for the
ratings of stuff that everyone's ratings
are down a little bit unless it's like a
con or four yeah like everyone's ratings
a dump yeah I think out good triple G is
and he only generates like three hundred
thousand two hundred thousand buzz this
business is changing so much and it's
interesting with Netflix - they're
they're generating so much new content
and and going into debt I mean they'll
start turning a profit but I would
imagine but it's sometimes you wonder
like are we there's so much content how
who's actually watching all these shows
you know and so that the audience gets
smaller and smaller they can track it
yeah the exact exact that's Arjun Rogan
cuz he's doing another special for
Netflix hopefully very announce that
he's doing another special in Netflix
and I was like how do you know the
numbers seems like they don't give
numbers but you know what your view if
your offer goes up stuff like that it's
gonna be yeah they're looking at those
yeah they know brilliant a ticket number
to integrate because it does keeps you
young okay average I do know groups know
what well you're someone between Dave
Chappelle and you know yeah and the low
yeah
you're somewhere in between you know -
was the most successful most watch Tommy
special of all time he's wearing Netflix
really yeah
after all that time yeah that show was
so big on Comedy Central so big it's so
great I like I watch it the other night
and my weed pen was watching tonight you
know salad that's Italian has a path
there and it's still it's so funny still
relevant man that show is so [ __ ] -
by Chappelle show yes
they're just showing reruns and I was
laughing my app yeah it's it put him
over the whole area yeah he's such a big
star when he's on there but debt that
was how many years ago more than 10 play
literally right at least 10 look it up
crazy and peeled kid he disappeared yeah
King Pele came along and they're killing
it
yeah Pele real is right because Pele did
the movie get out Oh God
talented Chappelle shot at 2006 hug and
11 years ago wait original 2003 yep yeah
yeah his run with 2003 2002 2006 on that
well I saw him do when he write his
first year so it would have been I was a
senior in high school so I've been 2001
2002 2001 - gun - I saw him to stand up
at the Fillmore in Denver yeah I've
never laughed so hard in my life
really oh my god he's gonna Sesame
Street bit oh my god it was brilliant
[ __ ] great I never stressed thing
I've ever seen
he's such a monster man it's so cool
yeah it's cool he's back doing it yeah I
think he's doing a lot of it - he did
the store sometimes I work and stuff
yeah I got I got that thing on stage
where I was about to go on and then I
came in into the new guy like - two guys
going before you they should have went
up before me okay cool okay let's go cat
do you see uh rolling film new studio
yeah I saw yesterday it's close to his
out now silly really big Wow bye too big
let's cool house today
well if he wants like store cars instead
give you cars are you letting a jail
every rocket he has a whole car chewing
he's you know video game thing in there
yeah just to Matt's like a full gym
there's a sauna cryo chamber there's a
grill
why not jamie has his own office really
yeah great yes his own office great yeah
see me sick I think we're into companion
like September night or something around
there okay yeah I'll be the new how yeah
yeah fun role a little bit too little
roughhouse Sunday and now we got Matt so
you have no excuse I know
damn brother hey no I'm saying telling
builders ha brother silly Billy no but
listen brothers what I'm saying is this
and it's all good it's rough house
Sunday so if I get all handsy on you my
hands my coffee boy will freak out no
but just relax brother this is brother
so and car you won't call me call your
boys and call your boy when I got your
leg up in the air no no no I'm actually
mobilize I mobilize your head races we
mobilize your hips you call me bro don't
have it boy cuz all now I want for a
minute race what does a QB tzu-yu he's
filming city college racial tensions I
know cam it sounds like I don't know I
wanna I almost like feel like if they
had just not given any [ __ ] media
attention to those morons just none like
just let the 200 and morons who are
neo-nazis March they all exist we know
they're out there and just I don't give
them him say no terrace no don't wanna
show on okay I'm just let them do how I
wanted to show up
I saw schemas for their asset so they're
doing a march in Laguna Beach like you
[ __ ] don't don't do see any
their core we're gonna be horse if you
touch any of the cast from Laguna Beach
MTV series I'm gonna bomb good but you
know not as people you chord them off
you give them all you give them plenty
of room yo sit on the sidelines and
waddle no watch all knows it all snicker
on the side there we go that's the old
like it don't counter protest no just
let me all know you're not raised of
March around I are living in the end
guys good you guys tired cool you wanna
keep going what do you guys want warrior
yeah you want you want Gatorade what you
guys want you run by like Samaras on
water and then I would do that I would
literally do you know work 7:00 a.m.
rush hour you guys care is it cool
yeah like just let me do a hundred zero
ten I agree 100%
I totally agree just [ __ ] literally
don't show up let them walk let them
model no tents no baby other than nada
thinkers March let them freak out okay
great who's racist is damage they were
protesting I guess it started with
protesting robert e lee now let's go
through this i was going to do this into
dropping knowledge but I may as well do
it now because let's just talk for his
lab and Charles foo so insurance ville
robert e lee was the be the
general for the for the Confederate Army
okay domani ulysses s grant was the
commander for the Union Army great
sentiment and yes it was and robert e
lee was the commander for now if you
read about the Civil War Robert Lee Ely
is many times he was a Southern
gentleman he was a slave owner and so
when you read accounts of robert e lee
you read he did write letters and i've
read some letters that that essentially
talk about him saying that slavery is a
moral and political evil on the black
man but he said alone them well but it
gets way more complicated than that
and he but he would say essentially that
the the black needs slavery for
discipline for discipline and it would
shouldn't be over until God wills it so
and so there he had this idea that that
obviously white supremacy was in his
bones so let me keep going on as robert
e lee also owned a lot of slaves and was
according to several historians i'm
getting this from the atlantic that a
listener sent but i but I also had read
a lot about Robert II we all keep going
was you know Robert Lee was was a was of
slave owner who would break up black
families a lot of slave owners actually
like Washington didn't break up black
families it was always because those
black families would be there for
generations so you'd have these huge
huge families so when you break up a
black family it was we think about how
traumatic it would be when you said
we're going to take your
fourteen-year-old son and you'll never
see him again and in fact after the war
there were so many stories of black
families looking for their kin and you
can imagine right you can imagine at the
end of the day at the end of the day you
know Robert Lee not only broke up black
families and we did it all the time on
his plantation but would believed in
physical discipline would give them real
lashings and then watch their facts with
Drive so [ __ ] sister so when you're
black and you have there's a statue just
say you're a black man forget any other
race for a second and you're in the
South and there's a statue honoring
Robert Ely he's on a horse with a sword
would that be right over the statue of
Hitler well
well a lot I think so because while
they're filing for human fighting for
what he and he insisted he wasn't
fighting for slavery and other quality
or was a lot more complicated I
understand anybody who's a historian but
but the fact of the matter is that if he
was fighting he was fighting to keep the
institution of slavery alive
ken Abbott was confined to said black
people were considered property to
robert e lee and even though in his
letters he expressed sort of this idea
that slavery was a moral and political
evil he didn't think it was man the
white man's job necessarily to end it it
was God's job well okay where was he a
complicated guy I don't know but if I'm
black and and a guy was leading the
Confederate Army and by the way another
very important fact during the Civil War
when they would come across black freed
slaves or black men they would rien save
them you know what I'm saying so in
trouble they had a statue of this guy or
and so er so so you'll ask people
they're like let's get rid of a madam
[ __ ] there a lot of not just black a
lot of white people were like I don't
like this file you know as I learn more
about history I don't want I don't know
why that everyday now when you read
history though and you read about the
Civil War robert e lee was constrained
very often as a brilliant tactician
which he was and also a guy who was very
very distinguished sober and a very
Christian man he was very religious okay
and and so totally made or eclis
accurate yeah but you've got to realize
at the end of the day it's like the guy
was fighting to keep slavery in place
there can be no greater evil when you
take when you own human beings your
Trump tweet it up now it's a shame we're
getting rid of these statues because we
knew you know because it's something
like we need to learn from our history
not knocked it down it's a debate that
you could make so you could say
Stonewall Jackson another chin just so I
get it right before people watch Jackson
was a snowball Jackson was a commander
and called him I believe they called him
Stonewall because he would stand it
wouldn't dock from the bullets and was
very valued
yeah it's made up well whatever the case
I do think that you have to ask yourself
if these statues ever fizzle out so I
might be goat yeah sad to see the
history and culture of a great country
being ripped apart with a remove our
beautiful statues and mommy monuments
you can't change this to be can learn
from it Robert Lee Stonewall Jackson his
next Washington Jefferson so foolish
also study what general person in the
United States did terrace when caught
there was no there isn't there was no
more radical Islamic terror for 35 years
it's it okay so the beauty that is being
taken out of our cities towns and parks
will be greatly missed and never able to
be comparable comparably replaced again
so there is a question here of the
Solanas Jefferson Thomas Jefferson
George Washington did own slaves however
we also know that they were our founding
fathers and they stood for something
bigger there there is that question of
when where do you draw the line right
where do you draw the line
I would suggest though that with robert
e lee or someone like that who fought
who fought and killed to preserve the
institution of slavery i can understand
I can say keeping and saying it's a
piece of history it's been there a long
time I can also understand if I'm black
or if I'm if I'm a real student history
gone that statues offensive because
you're honoring this is a lot if it's a
sense of the black people you don't need
to have it out there if it is it if it's
offensive to them and they live in that
community you don't need to have that up
I agree with you really don't I mean
personally at when I see the Confederate
flag you know it stands you know if I
was black I see a confederate flag what
you see in the South a lot and you know
and maybe they'd be out there'd be
arguments there but I'll tell you and
maybe it's not my history and stuff it's
not a very welcoming symbol you can
understand understand it a lot your
thing is like I'm partial to the right
I'm a white privilege American here so
when I think inverted flight doesn't do
anything for me what bothers you cool
get rid of it yeah it doesn't do
anything for me get rid of it yeah it
feels hostile to me it feels like we
lost it or but you know it's like this
is my flag and [ __ ] you guys I mean I
you know there is that
there is there there is I'm sorry but
there is feels like an underlying
violence when I see that on a pickup
truck you know it's my job to dig up our
top pick it's called pattern record
right when I see you on pickup truck I
don't go oh that's cool I Amelia oh yeah
and listen where I was for example in
the Panhandle these are these are good
old boys a lot of Miss Southern good ol
boys and a lot of art and I had talks
with them about this and a lot of them
in the project are good to know they're
good guys and I talked to him about this
and I remember the guy said I'm a
Republican I voted for trumpet I'm not
prejudiced
I'm not press I hear they're labeled
like publicans is not because I didn't I
don't like I don't like the word
Direction countrymen but I'm not a
leftist yeah a lot of its fear a lot of
it's like or don't like the way the
country is calling they look at it they
think there are marks it there are
socials and they're killers in me the
exact same thing so Trump was the one
guy who they thought would be different
yeah and I think there's the perfect
storm for him to get the gig yeah and I
feel like they feel like their tradition
in their heritage which isn't
necessarily all like just we hate blacks
their heritage is being attacked and
when people feel that way they get very
very very angry and aggressive
especially when they think the world's
against them and I think that they're
being marginalized and they think
they're being shrunk down to a marsh you
know a marginalized group right so we
got to figure it's it's tough man I
think it's going to only get worse I'm
very worried because I think is the
economy changes we become more automated
more and more people are gonna be out of
jobs man and and so blue-collar jobs and
manufacturing jobs and they're all it's
already happening it really upset yes
yes and what happens when young men get
upset what do they do need someone to
point the gun they need somewhere to
point point bright anger right together
they run over people they run over
people well they feel insignificant and
here's the other thing one attention
yeah and here's you're going to be heard
ask me it's because there's so much
information out there you know there's
just so much information we no longer
have any place to really trust like the
institution that we put our trust into
which was the church which were the the
old newspapers which was Walter
Cronkite's at Google even school who 1%
now it's all up in the air man so nobody
has any
an anchor we don't have an accolade
let's say you're a lost soul and you
want to go then and say man what is the
Confederate flag really that bet you're
gonna find what you want to find right
and if you gravitate or diet group
you're going to find you can find where
you can find GM leasing you literally
anything Jews are trying to kill
everybody you know Jews are trying to
take over the world you could find that
religions actually have smaller brains
than what you can literally find any
what whites are you know athletic is
blast you finally got true but you can
clean in fact creams are good at math
also true the tupinambá team is a boy in
it I'm at the point is that's my bro
sign you're right and that back in
autumn area knows kungfu we're a
directory he's no scoonpooh chins a
black belt with chopsticks right away in
a way but i was a m-- you can find out i
knew in some instances it's true no look
it's like because I'm white and get any
club correct the bottom line is it's we
don't know a lot of people don't know
where to get their truths from because
nobody trusts institutions a lot of
people don't trust the media everything
no I'm blamed with everything though
like you let's say you want to do a diet
I can find like when I was researching
pescetarian or entertain I went on
vegetarian it said vegetarians are more
likely to die for the age of 50 than
anyone else like Jesus Christ yeah you
really like oh my god some [ __ ]
serving then people who read me people
drink coffee more likely to live longer
we can't Lily whatever I'm certain for I
didn't find an argument for it then what
happens is this eating and everything
else becomes a belief system yes right
so all of a sudden you know eating
becomes a belief system when did that
happen
you have vegans you got paleo guys you
got keto guys and you and I know plenty
of people and it becomes a belief system
and what I like about what you say I've
heard you talk to people as you go do
you feel good when you eat it is it work
for you there you go there you go and
that's the way to do it be don't
everybody's in a cult we are we are in a
club or surfers yeah but don't be in it
being a cult of uncertainty yeah being a
cult if I don't know being a cult if it
depends and we really just living to the
evidence rizal all we do too late oh
speaking of which I [ __ ] up when I
said don't tread on me it's don't mess
with Texas I knew it and I apologize
like you should know what I was talking
about boat is and I've hired
waivers don't mess with Texas crest was
came up right up I was like that's from
the Marines yeah that's what I said yeah
you did now you are like I think that is
another reason I don't around me yeah by
let's just keep going all right with a
some guy really nicely correct me
because by the way I'm marine just so
you know don't so don't mess with Texas
was the slogan they came out with that
worked wonders and they were got let's
go let's do don't mess with Texas please
and they're like that won't work
don't mess with Texas people stop
littering in they do and that goes back
to what we were talking about they say
if you're talking to a conservative and
you want to convince him use words like
Authority use words that say you know
you know the delineation between
leftists and writers yes leather so so
so so like left-wing people who are
really liberal they tend to have
compassion for the weak right wing
people conservatives have compassion for
or have respect for authority and strike
those are two very different things
completely doesn't mean you can't have
both yeah but a lot of times a guy in
the middle oh so am i but I mean people
break up in these teams so liberal to
say they like change they're very open
to change conservatives are not open to
change conservative wait wait a minute
things are developed this way for a
reason you start [ __ ] around with
that the things and things could fall
apart there are a lot of really
interesting psychological traits that
are actually inherent to conservatives
and liberals and guess what you need
both in what happens is both teams
attack each other and they're not
attacking the problem because we all do
that we break into teams we get
competitive like when we are ival it's
tribal when it all tribal we're all in a
cult we're all in a cult and and and you
have to avoid it as really hard not to
be but I feel like like the more you
learn the more uncertain you get which
is probably a good thing because that
way I don't get responsive to the
evidence yeah listen don't join a team
nothing in join a team well see
open-minded yeah and you can and you can
draw lines like if guys were saluting
Nazi saluting they did you hear about
the American who did a Nazi salute and
Germany got his ass well it's illegal
how funny is it I believe he did in
front some statue he was like what the
[ __ ] he does me like cool to do no they
beat the [ __ ] up yeah he's a dummy
hilarious yeah you're not allowed to
it's actually illegal I think about
denying the Holocaust I believe in
France and in Germany is actually
a crime I can't do it not to school
around
now don't be doing that here's some
curve edge - sure let's do some current
events um Conor McGregor void me with
her don't you get it howdy I've never
loved psychology yeah how it's
officially changed eight ounces
announcer I'm Rogan yesterday it's the
Commission that decides to write yeah
well both parties have to so Floyd
started said let's do eight ounces
tonner agree took flop let's do eight
ounces and then the Commission has to
decide on it here's my kazoo z eight
ounces for if you're a hundred and forty
seven pounds or under it's eight ounces
oh it went for the sad no he's a career
in a town oh he has yeah so he's fine
even though they're both fine it listen
for it favors Conor rounds one through
six if favors Floyd six through twelve
it has is his damage on both ends so can
i one guy gets a huge advantage though a
big advantage if Connor lands with eight
ounce gloves he's more like to land a
knocked out than he was with ten ounces
it's not a huge factor Liam ten ounces
he could still not come out so it was a
difference between say a 14 ounce and a
towns in padding on the knuckles is
pretty minimal still right I mean for 25
40 ounces heavy gloves
no one's flights in 14 ounces so the
heaviest gloves to heavy boxes 10 ounces
so George Foreman Murali 10 ounces
really empty Joshua 10 ounce really if
you're under 147 pounds 8 ounces 10 out
there doing much this padding here it's
not much so ten to eight not crazy not
crazy but it favors Connor early on and
again you know Floyd makes all these
claims like oh let's do MMA after this
thing blows all the smoke to get you
know the headlines stuff like that then
when he goes [ __ ] let's do it answer
let's do 8 ounces and see how that works
out and I thought oh here we go this is
never get past my commission he's dead
serious
I think his thinking with that is you
know if he can start landing shots those
eight announcers are going to [ __ ] Conor
up pretty bad after after accumulation
of round around would be more likely to
stop them from the accumulation of shots
not a one he's not going to one punch
knockout Conor McGregor's I promise you
that won't happen but Connor can do it
to him that's why one through six time
aggregor 6 to 12 Floyd yeah worst case
scenario if you're Conor McGregor fan is
those punches add up and
can't answer the bell after the AIDS or
nights he's getting beat up so bad that
the worst-case scenario for us oh yeah
that's not gonna happen
I'm fascinated to see but those eight
ounces it's faster maybe it increases
the odds right stakes are high right
well you guys both spar and boxing oh
you spar at least in MMA boxing how do I
put myself in that category but I move
around even around but yeah you guys are
charged gloves on have you guys tried
different ounce gloves I my entire line
what do I fight with right what do I
have logic ten ounces I brought along a
fixed e now you use spar with six ounces
and work with 16 ounces typically for
the shoulder conditioning cuz the
heavier the club the more in shape your
shoulders will get and also 16 ounces
there's a lot more padding so when you
hit someone doesn't have the same result
as if a smaller glove no hurts the [ __ ]
out of me still [ __ ] her so I think eyes
get knocked down I've not guys out with
six ounce gloves in a Golden Gloves I
think that to wear 14 ounces I knock
guys out so if you have power with a 16
8 10 12 for your power yeah but for
Floyd you knock guys out with with
headgear enough yeah in Golden Gloves
all of them so but with Floyd you know
it's over time those eight ounces you
can take its toll the accumulations yeah
do you think about one snowball man 30
snowball 60 snowball yeah one big
snowball think about all those just get
God being after that yeah yeah it's
gonna take its toll that's what I
assumed he's banking on yeah it's very
accurate yeah what's the lightest ones
that you've ever had on your four ounces
I thought in you know seen 400 not like
sparring ones boxing ten ounces we spar
10 ounces listen man those 10 ounce
gloves is a heavyweight committing any
one 10 ounce gloves bossa nova similar
to four ounces with rats on pretty much
anything right eight ounces with wraps
on compared to 4 ounces wrap on same
thing really
and you sticker of your features that
aren't with 10 ounces you didn't spot we
swabbed 10 ounces before but typically
you do 6 ounce I feel like a heavyweight
it's like I feel like heavyweights is so
dangerous cuz I'm smart with 20 ounce
gloves on with Shane yeah that makes me
no different it made no difference it's
not you have to be a pillow than your
hand your shoulders get more tired yeah
but I feel I could like well you guys
hit so hard like it's
the shooting we shouldn't I shouldn't
have been spiral we shouldn't into each
other like that what else she gets in
all right this is very recent it's not
good news but sure you guys heard about
this in Spain Barcelona yeah Paris back
oh this is this morning yes I did not
tell you on a fan and yeah van into like
a sidewalk and just ran into people
so 13 dead 50 and oh my god and it's
still like the burning God you just
these [ __ ] guys man
one [ __ ] guy looking morons you don't
have guns you didn't give me any
attention
but okay next one thirteen dad oh god I
didn't know about this so a bodybuilding
mom of two she died from too much
protein holy ball somehow how do you
take you that's the thing so she's a
very elderly very connected to the outer
she had a rare genetic so do there you
go
but how like you know most people when
you're on a high protein diet depend on
the protein and I saw I've seen a lot of
guys in college football do this you get
kidney stones and your liver can't
filter out everything yeah it's really
stones you can't break down approach so
what happened with her so she has
something called urea cycle disorder so
I'm sure there's other people out there
that have possibly have this she was
just taking more protein that your body
can handle her kidneys came out of
something so ammonia built up in her
blood
oh one of the fluid in her brain oh wow
you can smell an ammonia and
bodybuilders sometimes it's funny
scrolling down to you you can smell when
guys did too too much protein you can
smell it god damn it that's horrible
that's part of her corner like it's
listed in your corner official cause of
death was intake of bodybuilding
supplements she and she didn't see any
symptoms any sign of that nothing just
[ __ ] I felt weird
god damn it yeah what else we go chin
alright my friend's husband died that
way you guys I'm bound so I'm gonna take
a nap protein all nap just died
let's see that's different but he was in
from supplement there wasn't a guy six
little skirts dude this one's a very
very weird one this woman from Alabama
she's 25 years old
Lisa Farris she went missing a month ago
my she got found
Alabama
right hello what's up so she got found
that was heard before
yeah did she find a spray tanning
machine okay I think she's gone for a
month in the woods who know if the
sunburn got to I'm the woods it doesn't
I mean there's like areas where she's
not really you know but check out so
wait look at her here she actually looks
a lot better
oh she looks good yeah I'm not mad at
her but look at her body so she had a
bunch of bug bites
tore up everywhere so how the [ __ ] did
she get lost so check this up she
doesn't know how she got lost she the
last thing she remembers is she went
with two guys into the forest two random
guys and they wanted to go break into a
cabin and she's like I don't want any
part of this
so she bailed and they broke into a
cabman stole like forty thousand dollars
worth of stuff in the cabin they got
arrested she went missing for the entire
month
she lived off of berries and mushrooms
and puddle water and mushroom and wild
mushroom eating ran random mushrooms
lost 40 pounds some woman found her on
next to the side of the road and she was
naked no shoes and she she's actually
like we call it legally blind she's
blind and a legally blind or she's blind
before and find her way our God God hide
our way out there's even more to it
apparently she was she was a retina
rushes but she was born right there two
days earlier before she was missing no
one so she had a disorderly conduct
charge right around the time she was
posed to go to court she went missing
two days before they dropped the charges
because they thought she was dead when
she was gone for a month and nice little
turtle she went on that I called the
cabin diet where we [ __ ] up teryn I'm
going like cabin - you wanna Kevin died
dude she's not bad-looking now her eyes
are gorgeous but not KFC she legally
blind so I mean I'm sure she could spend
enough going Ringwood you never have to
do your hair or like dress well when you
date her but she is yes she's attractive
Liam she'll get speciated what a
terrible if you're lost in the woods
yeah dear listener Allah's door Jordan
but her face is all eaten up I'm insect
that she did all those bug
couldn't find a way out could not find
her way out line yeah she could been New
York City
yeah I'm [ __ ] Manson in Chicago
Alabama Alabama Larry you look very
strange say uh some strange so maybe
something I had not but I guess
poison ivy stings when bugs probably got
hold that ate us know discriminate now
don't discriminate now ready their
titties by all eaten up they just don't
discriminate God then you go back of
your head she's a pretty girl man fill a
DSL runner eyes are eight babies
mushrooms how'd you know which berries
and mushrooms to eat I think at that
point you just eat because you have to
eat rooster teeth or straight before but
there's so much to this this is weird I
like that when you look up anyway
there's the mystery type move them girl
type movies right you'd win uh easily
when they can afraid when went alone can
you go down from you've even said that
to their like she was naked and afraid
they could naked afraid to blind that's
okay yeah that's Nathan Frey with no
eyes that's not gonna work she killing I
didn't grope your way around she's kill
me game yeah hello he found people
stayed yeah spit up at your this protein
in there don't mess with get laid I hear
you buddy not let me check
no there's no teeth on the friendly
snare night your hardest [ __ ] dude yeah
nice shorter snake now he's like stuck
in a big old long thick snake you know
he's poking his head out
don't put your mouth on him he's now he
gotta calm down man you know what the
only way to get back in it you know your
warm up with your mouth yeah my name my
name is John John I'm gonna live like I
got ready yet to survival record and I
got red head in a clubfoot if the cops
at my survival score is a 10 let's go
ahead and take the snake before you it's
real upset her she's a blind girl who's
obviously been eaten by bugs
can you she said I do I go let me
starving and put this blanket over you
[ __ ] Nigeria let me get you some warm
soup right here and hold on to this just
because you can't blow on this low floor
- look guys this is a handle on this
lets you know leather handles unify the
I don't hear some warm soup there's a
fresh old loaf of French bread it's a
little stale though the guns just suck
on it two Mormon oh that's that big
that's a big dog a baguette
you got a thick piece I've seen your
pink that's taking one oh it's one of
those like weird French ones I'm a
little Italian sandwiches red stick you
like a bread stick uh-oh
what's up girl Oh put your starving
crazy I found sold stale crazy bread
from Caesar's Little Caesars of Caesars
I get that little Caesar sighs that
crazy bird dick now I'm not say I
wouldn't do that I go listen
oh let's go I found on the log some gold
still I'm crazy I really your eyes are
so beautiful you can't see well poor
thing listen I'm good I'm a celebrity
first thing and I'm gonna do you a favor
I rescued you this is my dick that's
your reward
totally they do have a good unit I'm a
good-looking professional athlete I
would just live but they listed
yard-line say I'm a celebrity you're
seeing Titanic
huama in that so shame too [ __ ] up I'm
glia an average recap if you've seen
friends all right I also directed that
and created that so he wouldn't know
that now this is my I'm a new Batman
here's my dick let me repeat Batman
bat now let's go ahead and suck this
dong or you're not getting off this
island alive this guy came in Alabama in
island [ __ ] and how do you know now
back to the crazy bread inhale back to
the crazy old stale crazy said we gotta
get you some nutrition right away ah
people like why was she naked why'd you
lose everything was a lot easier
clothing that first thing you do when
you're in the woods is keep your
clothing on see what I made to spy on I
don't know maybe go back to naked on the
side of the road you know when you're
blind over by Eggman yeah it feels like
she lost her mind a little bit they
asked her to um do you think you were
drugged by those guys and she said it
could have happened but I don't know I
think that answer is kind of weird right
it's all very weird yeah something is
but she got out of the gig like I
celebrate this she went on that cool
cabin diet she's hot she's tans funny
first of all to people but when there
were two random guys in the woods and
we're talking a cabin which really means
those guys are like let's bring the
cabin because I don't want my knees to
be on because this this peat moss
my knees we're getting a cabin so I can
get you where I want you we'll have
ourselves a little threesome have a good
time yeah I caught the cabin shuffle
what they're gonna do is the cabin
shuffle means run the Train on the blind
girl now how's that sounds these are bad
guys he's a bad guy
it just so happens they're 40 G's in
that cabin so they thought all right
[ __ ] the blind girl did the 40 G that's
what a blind girl take a hike
take a hike 40 G 20 bucks guide and then
they steal run off with 40 G's and so on
[ __ ] was a blind girl oh my god forgot
she was blind now she's in the water
can't fight her in them Alabama woods a
lot of black bear up in that damn
hardwoods a lot of black bear up there
so I would just love the deafblind girl
mmm
they don't care if she can bear hungry I
know you fun surprise I I mean I
celebrate she made it out alive though
that's crazy
something's up with that story yeah
because she was truly embarked oh let us
get you a good one
this up black dude older black guy 50
year old guy he's a blues musician and
what he does he goes to KKK rallies and
he doesn't try to convert the KKK guys
he just tries to talk to him be friends
with him and according to this he and
this is a net flood significant he
converted like hundreds I love this guy
we'll watch the [ __ ] I love this guy
yeah
and see that's the Netflix who play this
- trailer - off guys like this can we
play this on there I'll play the sound
at least I'm sure you can play it
[ __ ] at every given in this country
where the Gettysburg Address by Abraham
Lincoln and the I have a dream speech by
Marcus the king excuse me that this is
where he's dead he's in crazy shape and
gave that famous see watch men and white
men all you have is an etching in the
concrete
there's no Platte there's no sign
millions of people trampled all over
that night and realized and how
important this but is he says I have a
dream I call this stepping on the train
me dented of a musician actor author and
a lecturer I like him always said to me
they're all hopping you have this stuff
we don't want you burning as shameful as
it is you don't burn our history
regardless the good the bad the ugly
Trump Legrand pitches trouble greases
that's an interesting thing to say isn't
it I assure brulee in that each thing
that he said that because I don't miss a
module after this be how long is
distinction like two minutes
I keep going in a minute we've got
numbers as young as 18 and we also have
juniors on any one person you would
fight to the last bullet five people
okay so what can we all do together as a
nation help you save the light race help
stir the white road on this bridge is
red ball by planting [ __ ] on the piano
occasionally the full racket risk how
can you hate me when you don't even look
at me and tell me to my face while you
would Lynch me this country's been
through a lot we still have a long ways
to go an awful long way as news will
tell you oh man we should all be mayor
we have a society that has determined
that we should fear the black man give
that person a platform allow them to air
their views and people will reciprocate
you guys really think about this is he -
he made them exchange I think so I'm a
wallet inside programming KKK members
raising an interesting point because
here's the question here's my question
so we know what will most of us do right
which we go we see these guys marching
we go we were hurl you know moral
diatribes out of me you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and everything else we and so we both
shouted each other
right this guy's going there and
actually listening to what they have to
say and it sounds like to an extent at
least to a degree changing some minds
hundreds even if they come back and go
you know that black guy ain't so bad
see Jesus both here because because I
never set out to convert anyone the Klan
I'd set out to get ants an answer to my
question how can you hate me when you
don't even know me great question we
gave them that chance to get to know me
and they treat me the way I want to be
treated it's a great it's a great
question but remember what what happened
with what's-his-name Charlie black who
listened to Louie Armstrong 16 year old
race races southern white kid taught
that black people were inferior he hears
Louis Armstrong's music he goes this
doesn't make sense
this dude's plan a horn that's making me
want to cry he became the lead lawyer
one of the lures on Brown versus Board
of Education so changing minds is
possible changing hearts as possible we
always forget that the idea is to
persuade the other [ __ ] side and
what's going on with them are they evil
or are they scared and angry do they
feel betrayed what's going on here
very easy dude right usually Harriet it
I really I really study on racism is it
genetic ins and our bone stuff like that
they said what's genetic is to be scared
and skeptical people that look
differently yeah I see it in schools how
we stayed alive yes so you know with you
know
if you have the light Sun and gives
school and he's not familiar with black
it wasn't like a little scared ornament
not that he's racist but it's
genetically in his bones ago so evolved
we evolved to be suspicious of so if you
hear the rustling in the trees you've
evolved say that's a lion I'm an
ammonite err on the side of caution and
run the [ __ ] out of that's a lion
so we've evolved to be cautious of new
things we've evolved because of things
we don't understand
right because that's how we've had to
stay alive on the savanna and so I like
this idea and I'm glad you and I are
holding hands and understanding and I
want to make an announcement here we're
getting out yay we're gay we're gonna
change minds and I know the tool is KKK
rallies y'all just gay and I and I know
this how I hate absolutely no and
there's a question for y'all you taking
I can't even find when they'll suck your
dick Brendan's a [ __ ] big powerful
guy who could kick my ass but guess what
gay even though I've had more street
fights guess what guess what who you're
asking and the questions who's [ __ ]
who and I want to answer that question
right now
I peel his peach I peel that Brown
Steelers you're the dick title i peel
that peach and I break listen KKK I got
an offer for it I need an answer by
tonight
- like everyone you dicks my gosh yeah
I'm not come on bro I never will say the
race bro double race just not a KKK
Brian gonna dick nope I draw the line on
the oh no no I'm not I'm not second a
maybe your heart bro I tried it baby
change
I'll talk to and change the mind but I
can't do that and I let me shoot that
race of sperm in your mouth uh Willis
kitchen check this up lion meets a hippo
and then I'll let you see what happens
we I think the hip will [ __ ] them up
I love me aggressive hippo hippos don't
I'm not here alive can peel no out of a
big play that's got not like my tea
that's like the Dimitra star yeah Mighty
Mouse where's Brock let me see this they
way they weigh about two tons on hand I
need to find out how much they weigh
that means you get this able to sail
back out there please so the cat comes
up to the hippo hippo and just nudges
his back oh yeah it's just so curious
boys you know poodle and then check this
off
always jail and they stopped them
yeah that lives like Jesus you know what
in lines defense really a dummy just
yeah it's it around I think when they're
younger they're I'm the old hippo hippo
went you know I'm gonna crush your face
yeah I love them well I was trotting
away thinking eyes guys too fat to catch
me trying away and you look back he went
hey what the site was kind of like hey
man oh wow I was like you know what you
know I [ __ ] know why [ __ ] you if
you had the chance [ __ ] god I love that
well their chins at it that's caught
roughhouse Sunday unless you want to see
some how about this just a real quick
fight announcement and is instilling
versus Kevin gas ones back on that's the
rumor I wanted I want to see that
beautiful member 20-foot anymore I want
to Shanghai I want to see him walk off
in the sunset but they can't do it
fighters like this can't do it thank you
no no Brendan's frozen hold on hold on
let me Brenda [ __ ] over
it's got it's got them all iced over
yeah I you stay on flight past and
Shanghai yeah yeah yeah god sorry I just
I do did you wait wait am I in a weird
different world you say instance it was
fighting on fight bass and cheering cot
yeah yeah come on man have a wrap
I'll respect come on man you are legends
I know in that cream I love my best to
junior legend bono what legend Oh God
that does nothing for me he can't all
hiding
he won't stop fighting oh my dick gets
more aroused around a [ __ ] fat slob
okay god damn it are you pissed
goddamn it [ __ ] well I think we can end
this can't wait he take a hot piss go
and take a hot piss it's fun kids um
chin started mother wants to start
working out yeah I start up in his game
he's a big kid I want to see him you
know pack it on be cool if it turned to
like chun-li just Jack this [ __ ] dude
get on Utley you don't you're totally
Longley look at John strongly is the
girl
she's also a fighter but she's in shape
yeah if you get those kicks like that
I'd appreciate however chun-li Chong Li
Chong Li starting from bloodsport yes
you did you jacked you had might be our
goal that you're here before when I was
in high school he's Korean is yeah he
was yeah being played a Korean - right
yeah thankfully oh that's right he did
let's work he's your hero yeah well I
mean this body style yeah that's that
though let's make that goal you think
yeah let's get you on an ice get your
sign class cycle when strum down you
have all that be sick man you report in
you just start freaking out on us
let's get huge like geez nice current
events in Moscow it's like damn brother
or Dre waiting out on us I want to do it
when should I get on trt maybe when I'm
55 60 60 you think chin would you do trt
I don't know I would love to see if
Brian did it first
like rain you look like carrot top your
blood would be all you play I don't want
that guy all you don't be like that but
maybe when I'm 60 right I don't feel
like need it right if you don't my
[ __ ] what do I do you've seen kinda
mean a shame how think I need it cut
your sex drive it's been a while man so
oh no oh yeah oh there but it's my joint
you know what you're in in the drought
so help me do a little kick of trt might
help you know what we do in baseball
when you're drought what's that you
slump buster hey what's a swamp buster
Bend you guys know a slump but no man
what if it's all swamp Buster
slump-buster The Grateful type catch my
drift
boys I was always about the Grateful
types I was always about the may your
stand high you know you looking for
Madonna
when you need a Rihanna well sometimes
you get you know my Brianna I mean 40 50
year old mom or having kids or just a
Detroit hey hey
that's a sub buster okay yeah or you
just get hey let's get you a
slump-buster and get a girl for you kind
of a diamond in the rough you know she's
got to be 50 maybe she's know y'all
hungry
let's say 22 but she's a hardcore one I
think ever and she loves her big Korean
oh now looks at all or you get a girl
who's just
is a little bigger than most but is
strong you know some girls can be bigger
but they're hard like they're kind of
they're they're stocky I'm very happy
with that body type I've had good time
you'll to help I've had good times I
like smart women yeah I've had good
times with a soggy sake xsprinter chin
are you I think I'm gonna say it again
mumble you need Korean slump-buster
crazy no Irina wait what's your type
though
I guess Asian yeah but not necessarily
cream what type of Asian Philippines let
us help you here I've only been out a
lot of lady listeners are listening
Vietnamese are given ease that's what
you prefer
I've always ended up dating Vietnamese
very checked what if I get a Japanese it
goes against my country I can't do it no
see we I need brandy never see a Korean
[ __ ] with it I know that's why I said
that
I'm trying to you said whoever unless he
can look around if I bring a Japanese
girl over and she's sexy curve boom boom
pow how you haven't you had the Korean
mafia know that and well amen well I
need to know where no though now you
know well forty just shows almond agents
alright yeah and all right I'm all
together I get it not the child bring
your Japanese over no no he's gonna swap
or I can't have that basket violent you
know Bank long before you I thought
slump-buster that's a career-ender yep
some Japanese out we said Japanese hot
compared to like a compared to hardcore
one Korean I'll take the Japanese yeah
you'll do it put up with the hangers do
it you do it behind closed doors yeah
all know what she's I hold on I'm down
and do this but let's post this on
Instagram and you gotta you gotta you
gotta hold up a Japanese flat nope I
can't do it
boy no no I can't do it you disowned
yeah it'd be over you know what she's
hot enough I'll do some [ __ ] yeah you
see me with nicest leg just I mean
bottom eyes will all bang a racist I
mean I don't listen you're a racist I
don't approve and I started to say it
why would I come I'm gonna criticize you
yeah but for now for now pretend I don't
hear it
what hi I know you may meet me to down
with all the non-whites yeah I mean what
it puts us poachers were my headlights
and Kate alright lets out the eyes
that's weird
okay oh wait a second hey hey Abdul it
all kinds of problem
let me do and then when I love that
rally next week Laguna [ __ ] I'll be
there
oh you want I'm gonna pick you up buy my
tickets now online sure but you know why
we do it after then once you suck this
dick you're aces with ass look at max
I'm swaggin attached to the carpool
we're talkin let's do that soon they
come [ __ ] you yep see ya good luck at
your stupid-ass meeting yep raise your
rally yeah sure I was a racist for a
little while till it came till I got
good now back to figuring out [ __ ] I
like to Vietnamese I like Filipino I
like okay all right chill what forget
your black girl nothing wrong with that
how about I play a tall black bladder
like my sponsor hold on back up the
tracks anywhere like this nothing on
that you look down cuz you know what I
didn't look good you know why he's right
because you know why are there many
blacks in the career sharp oh by the way
um I don't know my friend Marshall do we
did so no so I know Japanese blast you
weren't crazy about what about
straight-up blond bimbo yes
oh yeah eyebrows raised up you're the
blonde
you're quickly you're into the blonde
Beachbody's who's not man all right you
deaf going on yeah his head was on a
swivel in London cuz they're just flat
asses everywhere I wanted oh right I
said oh oh hey what about if we put you
on the tinder bundle I think it's time
yeah I've been waiting for a friend to
sign about this Oh eNOS egg me on your
show guy the dating tire here she has a
plan can you get a new bit we are new
big a new segment you know on tinder
when it set up we're improved two girls
all right and I wanted to talk about it
I'm Michelle yep done yes chin daytime
effect gents will come up with a name
for the segment all right and by the way
it's called date and [ __ ] date and chin
installed date and [ __ ] and chin and out
at another restaurant bus date and chin
but they don't have to be ugly it's just
this you in the slop babe gin hashtag
slump-buster
yes it's a new bit one can be [ __ ]
great I'm excited about that chin we
sign up for a tinder for me tonight sure
bubbles bubble and let me pick the
profile vote
can't be too serious can't be too creepy
can't look too desperate can't have
cream flags behind him let him do let
him yeah he's good he'll be a style
consultant I asked
I'll also fill out your profile so we
attract from the ladies yep yep um what
am i God this is brilliant and you're
gonna start you start working out and
start lifting weight yeah I do and we
look good now you dress well now to get
your [ __ ] together get a good job and
then start from a good family right all
the learners tighten the torso like he
has a good meal he like you know he
knows he's a foodie smart guy loves to
travel he can say mark and sing sing his
ass discipline serenade you every finish
ago three sips might be six four I've
been sick for fat dick hopefully I can
eggroll I thought you max Unger I've
seen it like an egg roll
what a sick fake egg weird don't say
I've seen it looks like an old American
California roll are you doing what not
to cut sick old log now I'm not cut sick
one I got an uncut piece yep all right
dressing well good good family has a car
yeah fine a car so far sighs any job ah
what else you need to make a
slump-buster I like them this is easy
and what I you know I call this rod come
from Grand Slam your grants and Hey
ladies
you just got to Denny's [ __ ] it's very
nice I am oh did you saw where the Grand
Slam
here's chin hey gar in style hope you oh
you don't mind a guy with dark hair six
foot four
here's your Denny's meal Korean Grand
Slam ah guess what here's a bonus Oh
guess what ox for a dick boom Dick's got
these don't be like fast and furious
casinos cards as well he's is dong on
adultery hope you hope you like civics
ah oh yeah honda accord bill eighty this
guy drives the speedling oh you looking
for a big old spoiler wing on the back
that's and he in a bad burrito about
that annoying exhaust she knows exactly
where to get it you want to drop that
thing put some rims on sweet he drives
acidic and he follows the rules you will
his chin his chin chin chin I think I
should be detention that should be the
profile Chan dude this me the sixth
segment of all time it's kind of good
why wouldn't we find you real love you
get married
like I don't want you doing I show him
or [ __ ] mine and Brennan and there's
this big war yeah you break up the
Hebrew she breaks up the Beatles now
[ __ ] those guys she tell me what dude
they're bad influence but I know he's
talking about sucking dick and binds a
certified dick diver I don't want you
hanging out with him oh yeah she's black
ugly not [ __ ] they got job in the
club we don't got y'all up in the clubs
off in the club talking all that
[ __ ] I Robin Lee yeah talking all
that [ __ ] hey man talking all that [ __ ]
all the time dating funny to me I think
both of gay you can't hang out with them
anymore you can only work once a week
and then we got a problem
and now it's close to them oh by the way
chin chin I'm pregnant
Carson chin oh by the way little
ching-ching I'm pregnant by the way left
chin chin the info for yo ass I'm
pregnant
hey man she's real world star right now
yeah that's why I want to find him just
a shadow with just booty for day food
and it's too much for chin ah you have
you ever seen a Napoleon Dynamite like I
want that girl huh huh like the biker
from the be outdone lynching starts
coming uh y'all here's current event but
[ __ ] I just chill all right his current
events and just goes full black I like
super over lack he comes in and Gina's
cornrows which you love I love cornrows
Gina's cornrows and Carozza look good he
has a fake chain on yeah uh y'all
here's Kern event your bride shut up for
a second with a patchy robbery and a big
line drawn to it and his girl has had it
in and you can only talk to her through
him yeah it's big time hey y'all hey
y'all you want to talk to chin they're
tossed in here hair attention makes a
comment she goes preach yeah yeah she's
like she's like your flavor of you heard
oh yeah yeah yeah surgery like after
every turn Evette chin reads one he's
got uh y'all hears tournaments and she
goes woo all right fight [ __ ] you got
it you got a pipe down and can't be
doing every time Kermit what what hey
y'all ww geometries your shirts not
pulled up Rob here's your charity y'all
make sure you download new podcasts chin
chin and me all right [ __ ] you got your
thing yeah we do it live from Waffle
House [ __ ] oh
you hold a super stereo hold on I want
to be part now chin and you have a
podcast together from the Waffle House
yeah [ __ ] and I found hot sauce now all
right hey hi I'm not part of it
I feel like the auto extol not a bad
rule yeah there ya go 220 monadic right
now Chinchin hot sauce cheese domestic
grumbles chicken y'all hey [ __ ] 4head
hey boss better [ __ ] friendly she's
got her own shirt but why she freaking
out Master Kim Kim in this [ __ ] oh
you're making her do shy you're making
these imagine gerber bear on a
percentage very stereotypically very
offensive and I don't think Jin wants
dater and by the way I don't like he's
into it no he's not yeah and she's
nothing that was fighting a kid Brennan
Brian oh you're hot Wow it's like you
Shawn I said you bad though she's the
dime piece huh but she just evil like
yeah she's not on I'll I love you chin
chin and then I'll just take you how to
make him jealous by banging that no she
won't know she hates question I know in
the fact that you hate in this scenario
she hates us and then she's always
around chin all sound like chin let's go
on the road he's like dude I can only go
up shamiqua goes to well her name should
be Cornell it's myself II know I know
but this is very of certificate bomb oh
man we're living it very sensitive
region I know I'm out in and now your
attention to drilling into waffles is
your name is Shaniqua you're being super
oh and yeah buddy okay bye once you have
a flat ass white I'm a dentist
okay maybe she's a dentist with braces
and black yeah and she's like black girl
flat ass doesn't exist here's the thing
though why why can't I like waffles why
can I do a podcast from waffles that's
racist well alright bye line go home
awful no they hold hot sauce no no I
love hot sauce
I love waffle I just am identifying
guests from there with great drink not a
big deal wait why I get to go with great
drink Oh hold on great drink this I love
the time right now we got to go
I miss our get your mascara and cheers
hurts no no let's go eat something all
right Janet for reals though tinder
profile I'm gonna help you with when
find you funny good it's made us a new
sack I hope my dad asked me great shame
in with the chin chin and I mean Brian
give you
dating advice where to go on the date
yep so I let it take over your life chin
all right it's gonna be good as a few
things you only want to lease cars and
[ __ ] have tender it buy some big dude
he's gonna be lifting weights and
tendering it Oh dick and [ __ ] yeah
high profile ah don't ever wear a condom
make sure you have a lot of casual
advice in his life condoms for [ __ ]
don't worry if you're single condoms are
for sure what are you scared of little
syphilis we're scared of a yo you guys
you really stay no sir closing out where
those kids oh they're great chin you
feel about it and you'll be free to
figure out we'll bring case when that
welke the pool God half black half
Korean are they gonna swim cap black
half Korean Hines word that makes it oh
wait don't mean you can hide we work and
and I Benson Henderson there that's a
beautiful combination Korean and black
have a good cop haven't seen him in the
water legit like can't bad well but they
can fight and they that's why as a body
sports and they're badass [ __ ]
butyl Korean a black is a beautiful
combo yes you know what I think we're
searching for black yes you are yeah
y'all you got to have kids with a black
one that makes a beautiful child you
spread you doubt it on that alright
we love you everybody oh we're going to
be up on September 22nd I'm at the Laugh
act in Long Beach I am more date soon
good I'm at Madison I'm in Madison yep
twenty first twenty third second third
are like that 20 and then I'm in Philly
at helium
yeah no no no this is all in September
okay September I'm in Madison
later at 21st 22nd 23rd I think and then
I'm in Philly
you're DC the 24 now or not because of
the Conor McGregor fight had it had a
cancel Billy at helium 928 to 9:30
that's always one of my favorite places
and I'll be in Madison I can't believe
it's not up there I got to put it up
there Madison at T pack a.com for Bryan
tickets in Philly Madison and then for
me Long Beach lives of territory second
on more dates and out soon as usual I'm
so excited for this next segment with
Janice me so say hi this is the finally
kid we're out